Okay, let's see, oh god, it looks so much worse and up close with them, I don't even know what that is.
What is that? What?
Okay, over here, oh yeah, it does smell bad.
Oh, this has to be trash, it looks like crap, it smells like crap.
It does make sense that it's near a dumpster in this alley that I've had, but I just can't tell what it is.
Do I want to know what it is?
Okay, I want to just...
I want to know what it is.
Yeah.
Mm-mm.
No.
Wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Maybe it's like an animal or something.
I want to know what it is.
Okay, I'll make something out of this here.
Wow, okay.
I can't sketch it, what if I...
I don't know what it is.
Yeah, no, this piece of trash is way out of there, that's what I drew.
I don't know if I've seen something so disgusting.
It's like genuinely it is, I can't still look at it, but like for science, I'll continue.
Okay, a couple more rounds.
Here we go.
Okay, one of it's nothing more.
Wait a second, I think.
There's like something here, I think I can scratch it off, maybe.
Let's try again.
Good thing I always have my tones on me to look at weird things and have to face the ugly chef.
This thing is like kicked on, this is like mud or something.
Okay.
Okay, let's try again.
Okay, now we're getting somewhere.
It's weird, show me substance.
It's weird, trash and objects.
Okay, brush.
Yeah, what if I do this over...
I think it doesn't have a mouth.
This thing was sitting and I lost my mind.
Interesting.
My cats get out of here in the rain, I'm crazy.
Gosh, this stuff is so cute.
Okay, let's try again.
How do you even know what I'm doing?
What if this piece of junk is completely useless?
Okay, let's try again.
Okay, so I can figure out what even no one in this problem is even worth my time.
Okay, one second.
Okay, let's try again.
Okay.